this is a production of cornell
university
welcome everyone friends family and
colleagues uh
jennifer robin wilson is originally from
charlotte north carolina
she received her bachelor of science in
plant and environmental sciences from
clemson university
in clemson south carolina while at
clemson
jenny led many student organizations
including founding the clemson agronomy
club
heading up the igem synthetic biology
team
jenny explored different research
opportunities as an undergraduate
working in the labs of doctors huang wow
and widow schnabel in addition to an reu
internship
with dr sona pandy at the danforth
center
jenny was recognized with numerous
awards for her dedication to scholarship
and research
most notably an nsf pre-doctoral
fellowship
jenny joined my lab in 2016 to pursue
her phd in plant pathology
studying molecular mechanisms of
transmission of polaroviruses
from our earliest conversations i knew
we would be a great scientific match
during her time at cornell jenny has
been active in the plant pathology
graduate student association
serving as its president and treasurer
jenny has also been very active in
outreach activities for children
especially young girls through the
expanding your horizons program and girl
scouts of america
she has also been the recipient of the
national institutes of food and
agriculture
pre-doctoral fellowship and the barbara
mcclintock graduate student award
for unique and outstanding contributions
to research
jenny was awarded a snips schmidt novak
grant to pursue her collaborative
research with josh happy's lab
over the past year jenny has been
working closely with the cotton growers
to translate her polarovirus research
from potato into cotton
she was in she was awarded an
unsolicited grant from cotton inc
to identify overwintering hosts of the
cotton aphid and the gary a herzog
outstanding talk at the 2020 cotton
beltwide conference
jenny has been a true scientific partner
during her time in my lab
bringing some of the most challenging
projects to completion as well as having
her thesis
chapters all published or just about
ready for submission
jenny's research led to the development
of an invention disclosure
describing a new method to control
polarovirus transmission by aphids
i am very proud of her and her
achievements she has been a beacon of
knowledge for the newcomers in the
virology program
excitingly jenny was hired into a
special usda
ars post-doctoral fellowship program
funded
by ars headquarters for projects themed
high
impact and a national grand challenge at
the agency level
she will continue to pursue vector
pathogen interactions week research with
kaisu ling
also a former cornelian at the u.s
vegetable lab in charleston
with the focus on gemini viruses and
whitefly interactions
but for now please sit back and relax as
jenny takes you on a fantastic voyage
through polarovirus aphid interactions
thank you michelle um thank you for that
kind introduction
thank you all for for being here um i'm
very excited to share my research with
you all today
i hope you can see my screen um before i
get started i want to point out there's
a
on the right side of my slides there's
this red bar where you can put
everyone's little faces on zoom over
there and it won't interfere
with anything in the slides so my
dissertation research has focused on
polaroviruses so you may be wondering
what what is a polarovirus
so these are viruses um in the genus
polar virus and the family of
ludioverity that infect plants
and they can cause many different
destructive plant diseases
so shown here are three examples of
polar viruses we study in our lab
and you'll notice that each one infects
a different family of plant hosts and is
transmitted by one or a few aphid vector
species
so the main virus i focused on for my uh
dissertation is potato lethal virus or
plrv for short
it infects hose plants in the family
solanaceae including its most important
economic host potato
and on some cultivars it can cause this
net necrosis of the tubers that you see
here
thus making those tubers unmarketable
its primary vector
is mises persecute the green peach aphid
another important polari virus is cotton
lethal dwarf virus this virus is
currently emerging in cotton production
in the united states and affects cotton
and other hose in the malvaciae family
and maybe others and its primary vector
is a viscosity
or the cotton aphid another important
group of polar viruses are the cereal
yellow dwarf viruses
which infect grasses in the poissier
family including oats
barley uh wheat and maize and this
particular one rpv
is transmitted by raffle asylum paddie
the bird cherry oat aphid
so my my uh presentation today will
focus on
peeler v or which is short for potato
lethal virus
um so a little bit more about these
viruses so
here is a schematic of what we think the
virion
uh looks like so these firions have t
equals three
icosahedral symmetry so that means that
their basic shape is an icosahedron
and each face of this icosahedron is
comprised of three protein subunits
now our particular viruses they actually
have two different proteins that make up
their capsid
so shown up here is a diagram of the
genome of prv its genome is rna
that's single stranded in a of a
positive sense
so that means it looks like messenger
rna and it can be directly translated
into protein
it's only 5.8 kilobase pairs long
and encodes uh eight different proteins
so each of these boxes represents an
open reading frame which encodes for a
separate protein
uh the virus structural proteins are
encoded over here by these ones i have
colored in
blue and orange so the majority of the
virus particle or virion is comprised of
coprotein
shown in blue but at the end of the
reading frame for coprotein there's a
leaky stock
so this means that usually the ribosome
stops when it gets there but sometimes
it keeps going
and it adds this extension to the
protein which we call the read through
domain
and so this makes a longer protein which
sticks out from the capsid surface and
is incorporated into the capsid in some
unknown ratio
the most of it is still coke protein in
addition to vary on assembly these
structural proteins have been found to
have different roles
in the virus's life cycle for instance
the co protein has been found to be
important for aphid transmission and
movement in the plant host
through mutational analysis it's been
found that the internal region of the
rethor domain is important for aphid
transmission
so virus particles lacking this domain
are either poorly or not at all
transmissible by aphids
and the c-terminal region of this
protein has been found to be involved in
phloem restriction
so very importantly these viruses and
their plant host are only found
in the vascular system specifically in
the phloem
and this is believed to be a
co-adaptation for transmission by sap
sucking insects like aphids
um so to get successful transmission of
these viruses you need the interaction
of three different biological players
you need your virus vector and host
plant and the interaction between virus
and vector is particularly important for
these viruses
because aphids are their only natural
means of inoculating a new plant
host and the way they are transmitted by
aphids is quite interesting
we call it circulative transmission so
i'm going to give a brief overview of
this transmission process
it all begins down here in the infected
plant in the phloem tissue where aphids
feed
and when they feed and they take up the
foam sap they also ingest biryons
and these virions must cross two
important barriers in their insect
vectors
and it passes each barrier by a method
known as receptor mediated endocytosis
so we're going to zoom in to what's
happening at the first important barrier
the gut so to orient our cells on this
diagram
at the top of this image we're on inside
the gut in the lumen
and down here on the bottom we're
outside the gut or in the insect body
cavity and in between here is a
cytoplasm of gut epithelial cells
so this process begins when the baryons
are ingested and the virgins are
recognized
by aphid receptor proteins up here on
this top or apical membrane
once recognized they are endocytosed and
this is believed to be done via
a clathrin-mediated process um and then
they traffic through the cells of these
guts
using in these uh vesicles so membrane
bound vesicles
sometimes the virions line up in a row
and create this tubular vesicle you see
here
and they traffic across the cell until
encountering this bottom or basal
membrane
they fuse with this membrane and are
released into the body cavity of the
insect
from there they rapidly diffuse until
encountering the second important tissue
barrier
the accessory salivary gland where it
does everything all over again
backwards binding to that receptors on
that bottom membrane
crossing those cells fusing to that top
membrane and being released into the
salivary duct of the insect
where the virus particles can be spit
into the next plant host
along with salivary secretions for
feeding
so as you can see this is a very
involved process
and the relationship between polar
viruses and their vectors is quite
unique
mostly because as i mentioned the virus
depends on the aphid for its
transmission that's the only way this
virus moves in nature
and it's actually been shown that these
viruses manipulate their aphid vector to
entice it uh to transmit them and to
further increase its spread
the vector on the other hand it doesn't
need to transmit virus and there are
energy costs associated with doing so
but there are also benefits to being a
vector and that's partly why this
relationship is maintained
so one way that polaroviruses manipulate
their vectors has to do with vector
attraction and dispersal
so when polaroviruses infect a plant
such as potato they actually cause that
plant to produce volatile compounds that
attract the athens it brings the vector
in and once the vector feeds on that
plant it acquires virus and it has a
virus inside its body
and interestingly their preference
actually switches after they've acquired
virus and now they prefer to go to an
uninfected plant
so this encourages them to leave that
infected plant and go find a new host to
inoculate
and aphids are normally non-winged but
sometimes they produce winged forms
after crew cues like crowding so uh
these wing forms of aphids are sort of
what's driving the movement of the virus
in the field
another thing that uh plrv does for its
vector is it actually
increases vector for candy and longevity
so the aphids have more offspring
and they live longer and living longer
is very important for the virus because
these aphids remain viriliferous for the
rest of their lives so once they have
the
virus they will have it until they die
so if you make your vector live longer
that means that you're going to have
more transmission over the lifetime of
that insect
so that's one instance where the
interest of these two players
are aligned the virus wants to increase
the life cycle the length of life of the
insect and it also wants to live longer
but sometimes there's conflict and so
sometimes these interactions actually
involve a balancing act between
competing interests of
each biological player so today i'm
going to share with you
three different stories of this
balancing act one is looking at an
instance of vector manipulation
the other is vector defense how does the
vector respond to having the virus in
its body
and the third is has to do with virus
structures so close examinations of
the capsid itself has given us more
insight into these interactions
so the first story has to do with vector
manipulation
so the manner in which these viruses are
transmitted circular transmission
is actually one of many different ways
that insect vectors transmit their
viruses
and these different modes of
transmission exist on a continuum
from viruses that do not replicate and
do not circulate and only transiently
associate with their vectors
to those that circulate and replicate
which is a much more prolonged
interaction
aphids transmit a group of
plant-infecting viruses by a
non-circulative mode um the podiviruses
viruses and family podia verdi and these
viruses only bind the mouth parts of the
insect and stay with them for
only a few minutes actually on the other
end of the spectrum
example viruses that replicate in the
insect would be densoviruses which are
not plant infecting viruses they're
insect infecting viruses but they do
replicate
in this insect host as well as circulate
polaroviruses have been placed somewhere
in the middle
so they definitely circulate in the
insect vector and they've been they
are believed to not propagate however
recent work on other non-progressive but
circulated viruses such as the gemini
viruses
kind of cast doubt on whether they
replicate or not so we're curious to
re-examine polar viruses
are they doing some low level of
replication possibly
um and this is really important because
that really changes the nature of
relationship that changes a lot of
fundamental aspects of the biology of
this interaction as well as potential
management strategies
so we wanted to re-evaluate this
paradigm using a new technique called
small rna sequencing
and small rna sequencing takes advantage
of the fact that in plants and
invertebrates antiviral immunity
is largely needed by small rnas so
here's how it works
when a virus is replicating in a host at
some point during its replication cycle
it will make viral rna of a
double-stranded nature
this double-stranded rna is recognized
by enzymes in the host called dicers
and they cut the double-stranded rna
into these smaller pieces which are
called virally derived small interfering
rnas or virnas
and they're typically 21 to 24
nucleotides in length
a single strand of this virna is loaded
into this protein complex called the
rna-inducing silence complex are risk
and they're specifically loaded into a
protein called argonaut
argonaut uses that piece of the irna to
find
and destroy other pieces of rna that are
complementary to it
so this often results in the degradation
of viral messenger rna
and thus the downregulation of viral
genes and slowing the replication this
virus in the host
so we do some rna sequencing we take
these small virnas we sequence them
and we compare them to a database and we
say what viruses are present in our
sample
and those viruses must all be actively
replicating and the host is launching an
immune response to them
so in this way small rna-seq is a
powerful tool to detect if a virus is
replicating
so we not only wanted to examine if our
aphids
were launching an immune response to
these uh this polarovirus potato lethal
virus but we needed a negative control
which would be a virus that does not
replicate so we decided to use the
podivirus potato virus y
because it's also transmitted by our
aphid mises persecute
and it affects the same host potato so
here's our experimental design
aphids were exposed to a peel rv
infected plant
they were also exposed to prv in a
sucrose diet so you can actually purify
the virus from
the plant and then spike it into the
sugar solution which the aphids will
feed on
and then you can disentangle effects
that are due to plrv in the plant versus
just pov on its own
we also expose them to pvy so this is
that non-circulated virus
as a negative control as well as our
mock inoculated healthy plant control
so you guys are exposed to these
treatments for a few days and then we
move them to turnip plants for a very
important step that we call gut clearing
so we're trying to see if we find small
rnas to peel our feet in the aphid
samples
but when they feed on a peel or be
infected plant that plant is also
producing small rnase to plrv
so we had to make sure we cleared those
out of the gut lumen of this insect so
that when we sequenced it we were only
seeing
aphid smell rnas and turnip is a great
plant to use for this because it's not
a host of prv and pvy so the virus can't
replicate there and there won't be any
small rnas
detected from those plants or mapping to
virus anyway
so we extracted the rna from those
insects and prepared them and sent them
for luminous sequencing
and we've got those reeves back we
actually found that there were no reeds
mapping to prv in our avid samples so
this shows us that the aphids are not
launching a small rna response to this
virus and this virus is likely not
replicating
in the insect vector so this confirms
that paradigm that these viruses
actually do not replicate
in their insect vector but the story
doesn't end there
because we also saw reeds mapping to a
different virus
mises persecuted enzo virus which is a
virus in the family parva verdi it has a
single-stranded dna genome
and an icosahedral capsid so this is an
insect infecting virus
and so we saw these reeds and we thought
okay are colonies actually infected with
this virus
um because sometimes viral sequences can
be integrated into genomes and it turns
out there are a lot of integrations from
this virus
in the aphid genome so we want to make
sure what we were looking at here
so to do that we map these reads to the
densovirus genome
so the top here is a diagram of that
genome this virus produces three
non-structural proteins indicated with
the letters ns
and it produces two structural proteins
indicated by the letters sp
and down here is a graph that's to scale
with this mapping those reads across the
genome
and these gray boxes indicate pieces of
this dna uh they're integrated into the
aphid genome
and these dots represent the reeds that
we found in our samples that match this
virus and they're color coded by
treatment
so what you'll see is that these dots
are all across the genome that we're
finding reads of all these different
pieces of the dense virus genome
and not just in these regions where it's
integrated into the mises genome
so that does indicates this is an
actively replicating virus our colonies
are infected
and the reason we didn't know that
they're infected or doesn't
pose a problem is that this virus is
actually very mild and it doesn't really
harm the vector
all that much it only slightly reduces
fecundity and uh lengthens their
development
time but now that we have this actively
replicating virus we can develop primers
to detect it so we
designed our primers right here in this
intergenic region of the virus
so that when we use these primers we're
looking at genome copies of the
denzovirus
and not just transcription from the
integrations in the avid genome
so our aphids are infected with the
virus and they're launching a smaller
immune response to that virus here is a
snapshot of that response
so on the x-axis we have the different
sizes of small grenades that the aphids
are producing against this virus and the
y-axis is the relative abundance of each
of these sizes
so first let's look over here in this
size range 21 to 24 nucleotides this is
the typical size range of virnas
and it seems in our aphid samples that
22 nucleotides is the most abundant
however we also saw an increase in these
larger small rna
over here in this 33 to 40 nucleotide
size range
and this size range does not correspond
to any known class of small rnas
we also noticed this was only happening
in one of our treatments which is when
aphids are exposed to a peel or the
infected
plant but we don't see this when they're
exposed to the prv
the same virus given to them be a diet
feeding system
so whatever is causing this is only
happening in a pre-infected plant and
not just by the virus
itself so we don't know if this is
incomplete dicing of transcripts
or maybe this is some alternate pathway
that's being activated in these aphids
that are exposed to the peeler v
plant um but regardless it seems that
this immune response is altered
we're getting this different
distribution of these small rna
so we were curious if this altered
response was as effective at controlling
that other virus mpdmv so what we did is
we exposed aphids to an uninfected and a
peeler of infected plant and quantified
that virus using the primaries i
mentioned earlier
and we found that aphis exposed japanese
affected plant did have significantly
higher titer of the dense virus so their
immune response
is not as able to control the
replication of this virus
so that's interesting what may be
causing that um so when you think about
viruses
and small rna and inhibition of the
immune system maybe your mind goes to
viral silencing suppressor proteins
uh so these are proteins produced by
viruses to inhibit
some aspect of this pathway to interfere
with it somehow as a form of counter
defense
so the protein encoded by polar viruses
that does this is called p0
and the particular place that p0
intervenes is by marking
the argonaut protein for degradation so
this is what happens in the plant hose
but we were curious
the p0 protein could also be responsible
for what we're seeing in the aphid
vector
so to get at that i needed to deliver
this protein to the aphids
so i turned to a model host plant
cocaine event
and i expressed this p0 protein in some
leaves i let the aphids feed on that
protein
and then i quantified their amount of
densovirus i also had another protein as
a negative control
as well as uninfiltrated leaves and
leaves expressing the entire virus as a
positive control
and you can see that being exposed to
just the p0 protein
led to a significant increase in that
densivirus titer
which means indicates to me that p0 is
at least partly responsible
for this phenotype that we're observing
so we do not know whether p0 is
getting inside the aphid tissues and
it's you know interacting with things in
there to cause this effect
or maybe this is an indirect effect of
what p0 is doing in the plant
and work is ongoing to sort of
disentangle and delve a little bit
deeper into that mechanism
um so while we are on the verge of
finding a mechanism
we still what still remains is an
evolutionary rationale
why would plrv want to do this why would
it want to make its vector
more susceptible to an insect infecting
virus
so we looked a little bit more closely
at the literature about denza viruses
and it's actually been found that they
can
produce cause aphids to produce winged
morse
um so here is a paper from pnas where
they looked at a different aphid species
the rosy apple aphid
and so they had a normally non-winged
lineage of this aphid so
a group of these aphids that did not
produce wings
and after they were infected with a
different densa virus crowding caused
them to produce these winged forms
so here's an instance of one of these
viruses causing them to have wing morse
this connection between wings and the
sensoviruses was further solidified by a
recent current biology paper
where they looked at two different
lineages of the p aphid and they had
some lineages that after crowding q
they would produce the winged offspring
but others after crowding they would not
and so they actually narrowed down what
gene is actually responsible for this
difference in wing production
and it turns out it was a horizontally
transferred gene
from a densovirus that was just happened
to be more highly expressed in these
lineages that gave rise to winged
offspring
so again a different dense virus a
different aphid species but the
connection
is still there so we're curious if that
connection was present with our own
colony of aphids with our species of
endovirus and our species of aphid
so unfortunately all the insects in our
colonies were infected by
this virus so we weren't able to compare
wings or we weren't able to compare
infected and uninfected individuals
but what we could do is collect winged
and non-winged aphids and look at how
much dense virus was present in each of
those cohorts
and we found that the winged individuals
had significantly higher densavirus
tighter than their non-winged
counterparts
thus establishing that connection in our
own system
so if exposure to a pre-infected plant
leads to a greater amount of this
densovirus and more denselvirus means
more wing production
then we would expect to find a higher
proportion of winged individuals when
aphids are feeding on a pre-infected
plant
so while we didn't test this own
experiment in our hands we saw in the
literature
that fred gildow had done a very similar
experiment with a different polarovirus
and so he found exactly that what we
hypothesized
aphids exposed to a pillar or a
polarovirus infected plant
had significantly higher wing morphs
being produced after a crowding stimulus
in fact gilda found that the ability of
the aphid transmit virus was not related
to the increased development of elete or
wingmorse
thus he concluded the response of the
aphid must be to the infected plant
itself
which is exactly what we've observed in
our smaller experiments
we only observe this change when they're
exposed to a pillar of infected plant
and not exposed to the virus by itself
so we've developed a hypothesis for what
we think is going on in this system
after aphids are exposed to a peeler be
infected plant
their smaller immune system is altered
and this effect is at least partially
mediated by the p0 protein by
an as yet unknown mechanism regardless
of how p0 is acting on the aphids
after their immune system is altered
there is a proliferation of this other
virus they are not as
able to control mpd and v in their
bodies and they become more infected
this increase in mpd and v potentially
leads to an increase in the production
of winged forms of the aphid
and these wing forms can then go on and
better disturb
burst both viruses so we believe this is
an instance of vector manipulation
but again why would why would peeler v
want to do this this is so risky to make
your vector susceptible to viruses yes
some of those viruses are great and they
cause
increased wing production but some of
those viruses may be lethal
so in this particular instance prv has
to balance the
additional benefits of having more
winged vectors versus the potential
detriments of
the vector potentially succumbing to a
lethal virus so in this case the
benefits
must outweigh the detriments to cause
plrv uh to have evolved to cause this
manipulation and its vector
so that's my first story about vector
manipulation
but the aphid is not passive in all this
it has a say in this interaction
and so my next chapter is about vector
defense
so despite um all that we know about
this transmission process from electron
micrographs
the exact proteins involved on the
vector side of things
still remains unknown only a few of them
have been identified to date
so to identify more proteins in the
vector that may be facilitating
transmission
a very talented scientist in our lab
stacey de blasio decided to use a
technique called co-immunoprecipitation
which can capture protein-protein
complex interaction complexes
so here's her workflow she exposed
aphids to a peeler-v infected and
uninfected plant
and gave them 48 hours to acquire the
virus
after the 48 hours she extracted protein
from these aphids and was able to pull
down the virus and interacting proteins
using an antibody that recognized virus
conjugated to a
magnetic bead so this antibody pulls
virus and the virus pulls along
all these aphid proteins with it that
it's potentially interacting with
and then you can elute these proteins
and identify them using mass
spectrometry
so when stacy did this she found eight
proteins that were significantly
enriched and pulled down from regular
first aphids
so when you do these experiments you
have to compare how much of this protein
did i find
and pull down some veroliferous aphids
shown in blue as compared to
non-verliferous aphids shown in black
and these proteins enriched in that very
lifers treatment are likely to be your
interactors
so the protein she identified she found
a glycoprotein a collagen protein a
heparin sulfate peptidoglycan
three different cuticle proteins an
immunity protein c1 qbp
and paramycin a component of the cell
cytoskeleton
and of these proteins the one that was
by and far the most enriched was c1 qvp
so we decided to focus on this protein
for further study
so what is clnqvp c1 qbpp stands for
complement component 1q subcomplement
binding protein
which means that it is a part of the
innate immune response in humans
which is the complement system which is
a part of the innate new response in
humans
this protein also has other roles such
as an infection inflammation and
apoptosis
it's predominantly localized to the
mitochondria but it's been found in
other compartments of the cell
which is illustrated with some of these
immunostaining images over here
so in these images c1pp is stained with
an antibody and it's showing up green
there's a different antibody towards
tubulin showing up red and the nuclei is
stained with dappy
which is blue so in these bone cancer
cells up here you see that cbp has this
cytoplasmic localization
and this is consistent with localizing
to the mitochondria
down here in these skin cells c1qbp is
still green but now it's on the cell
periphery and this localization is
consistent with the plasma membrane
localization so it seems that this
protein can do a lot of different things
and a lot of different parts of the cell
but its primary role is an immunity
so i just told you how these aphids do
not launch
a small rna immune response to prv then
maybe c1 qbp is part of a different
immune response so not small rna but
maybe another
response is activated
so yes okay so when you do these co-ip
experiments
sometimes you pull down proteins
directly interacting with your bait
which in our case is virus
but you may have a protein interacting
to that protein you may capture these
tertiary and quaternary interactions
so you want to make sure these proteins
were actually directly interacting and
we wanted to independently confirm
this interaction so we presented this
data
at a conference and we were actually
approached by cecilia tamarindegi
who's a previous postdoc in stuart
gray's lab and now an associate
professor at texas a
m university and she said that's so
interesting you guys found c1 qvp and
your pull downs from prv
um verifies aphids i found that protein
in my these two hybrid screening
experiments so cecilia did ys2 hybrid
using proteins from the aphid shazamus
graminum which is also an important
vector of polaroviruses
and so she made it the c1 vp protein
from these aphids
with yeast strains expressing the coke
proteins of three
different uh viruses in the family ludi
and beardie including plrv
and this blue color indicates a positive
interaction between that protein with
the plrv
coprotein as well as these two other
luteal variants that this aphid
transmits
so this shows that cbp is actually able
to directly divine
bind plrv and it's interesting that
there doesn't seem to be a specificity
for viruses as if it transmits so apt-p
can interact with co-proteins
of several different viruses in the
family ludi of your d
so now we confirmed that interaction in
vitro um we wanted to see if there's an
opportunity for this interaction to
occur in vivo in our actual system
are these proteins in the same place at
the same time
so to get at that i did immunostaining
of whole mount dissected aphid guts
and here are some of my images so i
stained c1 qbp protein using an antibody
that recognizes this protein from humans
and it shows up as green in these images
so we're seeing it has a punctate
cytoplasmic localization
and it seems to be inside this large
network or matrix
the plrv protein on the other hand i
stand with a separate antibody and this
just
appears as red in our images so prv also
has a punctate localization but it
appears to be going to a different
subcellular compartment and so we don't
have a robust set of cellular markers
for
hemetrins for aphids um so we can't say
for sure what compartment c1 qbp is
occupying
but we could say that these the virus is
potentially in those membrane-bound
vesicles that were seen in those em
studies and the places where these two
proteins come together will show up as
yellow um and so we have a few places
where it seems these two separate
compartments contact one another such as
here and here and here's a
zoomed in view of that here these two
apartments coming together so
that may allow the opportunity for
interaction but a second
category of co-localization we observed
was along the cell periphery
so this is you know presumably an aphid
got epithelial cell
and the signal we're seeing on the
outside here is that strong yellow
co-localization signal between these two
uh antibodies so here's a zoomed in
where you see these two proteins seem to
come together along the cell periphery
which could potentially be the plasma
membrane
so we've sort of had this multi-faceted
view of this interaction we found via
two different methods that this protein
interacts with plrv
one of those methods indicates a direct
interaction so the yeast two hybrid
we've shown that they potentially could
come together in space and time
in the aphid guts to actually have that
interaction occur
but obviously there are other tissues in
the aphids that are involved so there
could be
interactions occurring the blood of the
insect or maybe the accessory salivary
glands
regardless it seems that these proteins
potentially do interact in aphid
but what is it doing what it what is the
function of c1 qbp and why is it binding
virus
um so to get at that i actually was
lucky to find that there was a chemical
inhibitor of this protein already
published and we were able to get that
molecule from the authors of this paper
shown here
and so i wanted to use this inhibitor to
inhibit the c1qb protein and aphids
and then see how well they transmit
virus so to do that
i again turn to a sucrose diet system so
i spiked the inhibitor into this diet
and i allowed aphids 48 hours to feed on
it
and then i took them through a
transmission assay so i gave them a
source of virus so these are pure
b infected leaves i gave them 24 hours
to acquire virus
and then i gave them healthy plants
which they could inoculate for 72 hours
and these are potato seedlings after
three days on the seedlings
the aphids were removed by a pesticide
application and then i kept each of
these plants
to see if it would become infected with
virus and that gives me
a transmission efficiency how many
plants became infected out of those i
inoculated
so here are the data on the x-axis here
we have the different concentrations of
this inhibitor that i tried
so 50 100 excuse me and 200 micromolar
as well as a zero micromolar negative
control
and then on the y axis we have the
transmission efficiency and i actually
found no significant differences in the
rate at which aphids transmit
virus after each of these different
concentrations of inhibitor
however i looked more closely at the
plants that did become infected in each
of these treatments
and i found an interesting trend tighter
and the recipient plant
increases with increasing inhibitor
concentration so again on the x-axis we
have my different inhibitor
concentrations and now on the y-axis
we're looking at titer
how much virus is present in these
plants so for
the zero and 500 micromolar treatments
we have lower tighter than 100
micromolar
of the inhibitor and at the 200
micromolar dose we see that this
difference in titer is now significant
so what does this mean uh for the role
of c1kbp in transmission
so as you recall this is an inhibitor so
inhibits the function of c1 qbp
and it seems when we do increasing
amounts of inhibitor we are also getting
increasing amounts of peeler v titer in
these recipient plants
so this to me suggests that maybe c1 qbp
is somehow a negative regulator a p orb
transmission so its normal function is
to either lower the amount of virus
these aphids are inoculating into these
plants or
that's accumulating in the insect body
possibly um
but why why would c1p do that what could
be
it's a negative regulator but what does
that mean for the function um so i
hypothesized that maybe the role of c1
qpp and immunity may be conserved
um so complement receptors in humans
such as c1 qbp have been previously
shown to recognize pathogen associated
molecular patterns or pamps and the c1
qbp protein itself has been found to
bind several viruses in humans such as
rubella
hiv and herpes simplex virus so
we've shown that you know cmqvpp from
mises binds plrv
c1 qbp from that other api binds three
different polaroviruses
so it seems that maybe uh this protein
is recognizing viruses more generally
so is it possible that c13vpp could be
acting as some sort of pattern
recognition receptor
in aphids um but again why would they
if they're doing that and they're
playing this immunity role why would
aphids
launch an immune response to a virus
that doesn't replicate
so i wanted to go back to this electron
micrograph
from some of the early studies of
transmission where sometimes they see
virions
in this lysosome-like structure in the
aphid gut cell
so here are the virions here um so
it's possible that maybe the aphid wants
to regulate how much virus is in its
body and it may be degrading some of
these virions i don't know see when tvp
is involved in that process it's just a
hypothesis
um but it's possible that if it may want
to regulate how much virus it transmits
so that the benefits it gets from being
a vector such as increased quantity
longevity
will outweigh the energetic cost of
actually moving those virions through
its body so i think this is again one of
those examples of a balancing act
each of these biological players must
make in this interaction
so that was my story about vector
defense this third story
we're looking at virus structure so
prior to my dissertation there were no
known structures of polarovirus capsids
and why that is may have to do with
protein disorder
so what we're looking at right now is a
disorder plot so on the x-axis we have
the different
amino acid residues of this protein and
at the top i have
indicated the different domains of this
protein and so this red line here
indicates about
half this order 50 percent so anything
above this we can say it's
mostly disordered so you can think of
that as floppy
and anything below this line has a more
ordered regular structure and are more
um probable candidates for structure
determination
it actually turns out these different
regions of this order may have important
roles to play in virion assembly
so this uh piece right here is what we
call the r domain
and it associates the viral rna that's
the capsid wraps around
so this disorder may be necessary for it
to form those interactions
and assemble the virion this peak right
here all this disorder we're seeing in
this region right here we call this the
proline hinge
because this is where that captured
protein connects to that protruding
read-through domain so it may need
flexibility in that region
to form the center to form that uh
three-dimensional structure
and this region of the protein the seed
terminus of the rtd
is highly disordered but it's actually
believed to be
at least partially cleaved off in the
assembly of a complete virion so this
may not actually be present in
the completed mature capsid so these two
regions are ordered though so maybe they
could be used for structure
determination so actually a recent
cryo-electron microscopy structure was
published for
the coprotein down here and we actually
decided to focus on
the internal portion of the read-through
domain down here
and we worked with a group of structural
biologists here at cornell
specifically with josh chappie in the
department of molecular medicine and
they decided to
go after the structure using x-ray
crystallography
so um i worked closely with carl schiltz
a former graduate student in that lab
and he was actually able to successfully
express and purify
this protein from prv so shown here is
an sds page gel and we see
large quantities of that protein there
he was able to grow crystals of this
protein and he used um
x-ray diffraction to solve the structure
of this protein so here is the structure
this protein forms actually two
different structural domains
so down here in the bottom in pink i
have the p domain we called it the p
domain because it protrudes from the
capsid surface
and it's also homologous to the p
domains of other plant infecting viruses
which also
protrude from their capsid surfaces the
fold of this domain is what's called a
jelly roll
so that's two beta sheets wrapped around
one another
the second structural domain we saw is
up here shown in blue we call it the cap
domain because it sits atop the other
domain
and the fold of this domain is a beta
barrel so that's several beta strands
twisted around one another
so it's not unusual to find two
different structural domains in the same
protein
but what is unique is how they are
oriented to one another
so now what we're looking at is a
topology diagram and this is if you were
to take the protein
and map it from start to finish
n-terminus to c-terminus and draw in
every secondary characteristic
structural characteristic you came
across
so these arrows represent the beta
strands that we see over here
and this diagram is color coded the same
way the p domain is pink
and the cap domain is blue and so
interestingly we see that the pieces of
the protein sequence that encode the cap
domain are interspersed between the
pieces of the sequence
that encode the p domain which is quite
unusual because usually when you have
two domains they're linear in the
sequence
one right after the other so this
protein has quite a unique topology
another interesting feature of this
protein is actually that it forms a
dimer
so we're looking at a monomer here but
when you put the two monomers together
you get a dimer
like this so we still have the p domain
down here in the shades of pink and the
couch i made up here in these shades of
red and the dimer is glued together by
the piece of this protein that we call
the c
peptide because it's from the c-terminus
of the protein
and so this protein only forms a dimer
in solution
it also formed a dimer in the crystal
and we believe it forms a dimer on the
virion surface as well
so we can model how we think it sits
atop the capsid so down here are those
coke proteins
and here are the two nrtd monomers
coming together
over the capsid and because they have to
be a dimer we predict that they are
present on the two-fold rotational axis
of symmetry
of the virion so um let's look a little
bit more closely at this dimer
so this is the same dimer but now it's
in a space-filled model and we've
color-coded based on the conservation of
each of these residues
so the residue is colored in pink every
virus in the family ludio verdi has the
exact same residue at that position
residues shown in white are a little
more variable and those shown in blue
are
the most variable so different members
of the family may have different
residues present at that position
so let's focus on the cab domain so we
take the dimer and we look at it top
down
um this is what we see here so i'd like
to draw your attention to these pockets
that are in this dark dark shade of pink
and these are residues absolutely
conserved across members in this family
every virus has the same residue at this
position
and so that would point to some very
important role for these residues
um and so because this protein has been
found to be
important this piece of the virus capsid
has been found to be important for april
transmission we hypothesize that maybe
this is
part of the site where aphid proteins
bind here maybe avid receptors
because previous mutational analysis has
found that if you delete this portion of
the protein
you can't get transmission so another
reason why we think this cap domain in
particular is important for transmission
is where we find it in other viruses and
where we don't
so the closest structural homolog to the
nrtd
is viruses in the family to dispurity
and so i'm showing here
um superposition of the p domain of one
of those viruses melanocratic spot
with the prvp domain and you see that
they line up almost
perfectly however this tumbus virus mnsb
has no equivalent to the cap domain the
cap domain is unique
to plrv and polaroviruses and so you may
ask are these
other viruses that have this p domain
are they transmissible by aphids
and the answer is that no they are not
transmitted by aphids and they do not
have the cat domain
so that to us is another piece of
evidence of the role of the cap domain
that may be important for aphid
transmission
so this structure has given us a lot of
hypotheses but how can we test them
so what i'm showing here is a simplified
schematic of how the virion
may facilitate binding with aphid
receptors so coprotein is again shown in
blue
the nrtd is these orange spikes and the
aphid receptors are these uh purple
pacman down here and i say simplified
view
because the coprotein has also been
found to be important for facilitating
with these receptors
but you know if the nrtd does play a
large role in binding to aphid tissues
what if we just flooded those tissues
with the purified form of this protein
what if they plugged up those receptors
so that when the viron came along later
it was not able to bind and we get a
knock down and transmission
and if that works then maybe we can make
mutations to this protein the purified
form this protein
and maybe it would no longer be able to
bind these receptors and knock down
virus transmission
so let's test the hypothesis so i needed
to deliver this protein to different
aphid tissues of interest
so one of those tissues was the
accessory salivary gland and so i
delivered the protein to the
them using a technique called micro
injection
so when you do this you take a
microcapillary needle and you stab the
body wall of the insect
and you inject the protein bypassing the
gut and
giving it access to the accessory
salivary gland and then to deliver the
protein to the gut i used our tried and
true method
of sucrose diet delivery so again that
they ingest the protein along with their
diet and it goes straight to that gut
tissue after i expose them to this
protein i wanted to test their ability
to transmit virus
so they i just gave them a source of
virus and i gave them healthy plans to
inoculate
i kept those plants and calculated a
transmission efficiency
so let's look at the micro injection
data so i had a no protein control
so this was just the buffer that i
injected the aphids i also had a
different protein i wanted to test bsa
bovine serum albumin which is completely
unrelated to transmission so
with this treatment we're just asking
what happens when you inject aphids with
a protein
and it turns out it does not change
their transmission to inject them
with bsa and nor does it when you inject
them with the nrtd
so i saw no significant differences in
transmission from this experiment
using this delivery method what about
delivery via the diet
so again i had a no protein control so
this is just the plain sucrose diet
i had my psa protein controls or this
other unrelated protein
interestingly i saw an increase in
transmission when aphids feed on the bsa
protein
which is actually something already
reported in literature they found that
this happens when you use diet feeding
for bsa
and any number of other proteins that
have nothing to do with transmission
which is kind of you know an interesting
finding but it was great to see that i
could recapitulate a phenotype observed
in the literature
so what about our protein of interest
the nrtd protein
when aphids are exposed to the nrt
protein it actually significantly
decreases their ability to transmit
prp so this uh confirms our hypothesis
that
the purified form of this protein can
inhibit uh transmission of the virus
great so we have our proof of concept
now we can move forward and make
mutations and test hypotheses about the
structure
so we made two different categories of
mutations we either made single alanine
mutations
or we had this um one form of the
protein that we mutated three residues
at once
because the residues were closely
together and they formed a cluster
so for the single any mutations we
mutated this one this one this one and
this one one two three and four
and remember this is a dimer so they're
also present on the other side
and the reason we chose these residues
is because they're on the cap domain
which we think is important for
interaction with aphid tissues
they were all surface exposed so that
means they're in a position where they
could potentially interact with aphid
proteins
and all of them actually had uh charged
side groups so maybe they could be
involved in electrostatic interactions
with the vector
so we made these alanine mutations which
makes them uncharged
and i put them through my bio assay i
let the aphids feed on them for two days
i gave them a source of virus but then
when i went to move them
to uninfected potato seedlings i saw
that all the aphids were dead
uh so i repeated my experiment and they
were dead again and again and again so i
decided to quantify
uh the death which is what we're seeing
here so on the x-axis we have the
different treatments i expose them to
and the y-axis is how many aphids died
so again we have a no protein control
and bsa
both of which caused very little of any
mortality
we had the wild type form of this
protein which caused a little bit of
mortality
um and then we had these five different
mutant forms
so mutants one two three and four as
well as the cluster
and so we found that um all except one
mutant form actually caused significant
uh mortality in these insects with
mutants four and cluster causing near
complete
mortality so this is quite um unusual
you know why is this happening why is
changing one residue of this protein
causing these aces to die in such high
numbers so if you think about how this
protein
you know binds aphid receptors or maybe
it finds other aphid proteins
what if it were to bind them too tightly
and those proteins couldn't perform
their normal functions and that could
potentially lead to the death of the
vector
so that's one hypothesis we have for
what may be occurring the virus has this
balancing act between
i need to bind to these proteins to get
through the aphid but if i bind them too
strongly they can't perform their normal
functions and i may kill my vector
so this to us may indicate that the
wild-type form of this protein
is fine-tuned to balance these perfectly
it binds with the right affinity to be
transmitted
but not kill the vector so that is my
third story about the balancing act
between these two biological players
so i've shown you three stories one
about vector manipulation where the
virus um knocks down the
interval immune system of the spectre i
showed you one where the vector may
fight back and regulate the amount of
virus in its body
and the third story was about how the
virus structure itself may be fine-tuned
to not um kill its vector
so this is all exciting but how can this
basic research lead to solutions for
agriculture
so i want to revisit that finding the
feeding aphids on the nrt protein
can knock down transmission of plrv it
turns out this is a highly reproducible
phenotype i did it many times and i
performed a meta-analysis which is a
statistical analysis used to test the
efficacy of
drugs or pesticides and i found that
when you pre-expose the aphids to the
nrtd
it reduces the chance of the plant
become infected on average by 44
with efficacy ranging from 22 to 88
percent reduction
so it seems that this may be a method
that we could use to potentially control
the spread of this virus in the field
but what about other polaroid viruses is
this something unique to prv or could we
apply this to other systems
so the chappie lab has been very busy
solving nrtd structures for us
and so they've actually already solved
two other polarovirus nrt proteins one
of which is shown here
this is the nrgp protein of turnip
yellow's virus and it should look very
familiar
you'll see it has the same p domain and
the same cap domain
the one thing that may look a little
different here is the c peptide but
actually they were able to get a really
high res
structure for this virus 1.5 angstroms
so they're actually able to solve more
of the c-peptide so this is just more
of what we would have seen in prv with
higher resolution
and if you were to superimpose these two
in her deeds you see that they line up
almost
perfectly so it seems that the structure
of this protein is highly conserved
across polaroviruses
which is great news because it means
what we found in pillar b may also be
applied
to other polar virus systems so i wanted
to translate this finding we found in
the lab with this diet feeding system
to maybe something we could deploy in
the field what if we could get the plant
to make the protein for us
so just that i again turned to the model
plant the coconut miana
and i translate expressed these proteins
so i expressed the energy protein as
well as the negative control protein and
i had my uninfiltrated control
and then i took these aphids through the
transmission assay and quantified their
ability to transmit plrv
and again i found that the nrt protein
preliminarily
does slow their transmission of plrv so
it seems that this delivery strategy may
work we could get the plants to express
the protein for us
so work is ongoing to move this protein
into our important crop post so to
transiently to
transgenically express it in potato so
we've worked with joyce vannack at bti
to transform potato for just that
and we're rapidly translating uh these
findings to the new emerging polar virus
cotton lethal dwarf virus can we use the
nrtd
as a new novel control strategy for that
emerging pathogen
and we're not just looking at using the
wild type form in this protein but this
mutant forms it well as well which may
actually serve as a novel pesticide
so we're hoping to add some new tools to
the toolkit to manage this economically
important group of viruses
so with that i would like to acknowledge
a lot of people because it really takes
a village to make a phd happen
i'd like to thank heclav members past
and present my wonderful collaborators
support staff
my special committee and funding sources
those shown in red are my co-first
authors
who contributed greatly to this work but
my time here hasn't just been about
science so i'd like to also thank my
friends and family
for all the fun times and their
emotional support
and also you know phd is kind of a
culmination of you know a lifetime of
learning
so i actually want to take a moment to
thank all my previous mentors none of
who are on the zoom call today
but just the people who instilled in
little jenny a love of learning and a
love of knowledge
and help me become the scientist i am
today and with that i will take any
questions via chat
thank you
all right chats are rolling in
oh my okay adam starts with the doozy uh
so adam bogdanov says great work jenny
uh oh i didn't have to read that part um
because the nrt dime rises
could reduce transmission in the feeding
slash competition experiment
result from destruction of the capsid
bound in arctd
can you get heterodimers with the nrtvs
of the polaroviruses it prevents
transmission of
any potential for engineering the plant
receptor to ignore
nrtd great question um so yeah i think
there's definitely
could be some interaction between the
um the dimer the purified form of this
protein and the actual virion form of
this protein
so there's actually some interesting
work out of one of our collaborators in
france
um where they showed that um
there's actually a piece of the nrtd
that associates in trans with the biryon
so you have
the pieces that are associated with the
biryan but also the soluble form may
actually
form associations with the virion as
well so that's totally uh
possible as a um as explanation of
what's happening
um sorry let me close my slack channel
real quick
um okay and as to your other questions
so we haven't tried doing any
heterodimers with the other nrtds that's
a very
interesting question because yeah i mean
how conserved is it right how conserved
is the dimerization
and any potential for engineering plant
receptors
so we have lots of great ideas for how
we want to engineer things in the system
and so plant receptor i mean there are
lots of plant proteins these viruses
interact with so there's a lot of
potential there as far as the aphid
receptor
we still don't know the aphid receptor
for mises persecute and for prv
so it's going to be really exciting once
that receptor is identified and maybe
that structure comes out how to see how
it
correlates with our structure and maybe
can further explain some of the
phenotypes we're observing okay
um
okay we have a question from mariko um i
have a question about your nr2d mutants
did you try feeding them to any other
species of aphid especially species that
don't transmit prv
i did um so i fed some of
these nrgd mutants to the cotton aphid
and
um which does not transmit prv um and
interestingly
it killed them too um but it wasn't
the mortality rates were not the same so
what's interesting to me
is like one of the most lethal mutants
to mises was not that lethal uh to
cotton aphid
so you know that's an interesting
finding um and
it makes me wonder to what extent you
know the nrtvs seem to be extremely
conserved but how concerned is that
aphid receptor
that you know the nrtds of a completely
different virus may be able to bind them
so that's also
um makes us think about the biocontrol
potential for
for these mutants as well um
i see lots of congratulations um
oh a new question
yes so we have a question from igor he
says um
based on the charge change of those nrtv
mutants is there a way to test in vivo
if they bind tighter to the aphid
protein
i don't know about in vivo there are
definitely in vitro binding assays you
can do
but a lot of those require you to know
what your binding partner is so that's
part of one of our limitations here is
we don't know
um the aphid proteins it's binding to we
do have plans to do like coips with the
nrt protein and say what is it
binding to in there um and we also want
to do some microscopy to see
you know where is nrt going in the gut
are we seeing more binding
you know qualitatively with these
mutants versus the wild type forms
so excellent excellent question
okay well i don't i don't see any more
so wait oh wait oh
oh okay i got one um so
chris asks are there known receptors
host receptors in the gut that mediate
virus endocytosis
yeah so there are some known for other
systems so
for a different virus in the ludivir
family and the p
aphid they found a protein called
aminopeptidase n as a putative receptor
um for mises persecute they found a
protein they think
may be a receptor for some other polar
viruses so for that turnip yellow virus
and then another one
uh cucurbit aphid borne yellows virus
they think they actually have the same
receptor which is quite interesting
um and that protein was called um
ethernet receptor
um but one of our huge limitations in
this system is our functional assay so
people keep finding these potential
receptors but we're really
struggling to actually validate them so
that's why all of these receptors are
only putative at this point
yeah so claire has a great question so
she said you showed that the virion
interacts with an aphid protein and that
can influence transmission
um could the impact appeal or be on
aphid behavior after acquisition be
mediated through similar mechanisms
you confirm that this virus does not
replicate an insect so she's wondering
how changes in aphid behavior occur
um yeah it's an interesting question so
i think
the you know our work with um the p0
protein shows that
virus proteins produced in the plant may
somehow have activity in the aphid
whether they're getting in or not
so that's one way you know prv can cause
these changes in the aphid
without replicating in them is like
using the plant host to make the
proteins that it uses for that
manipulation
um very interestingly that finding that
the api preference
switches to uninfected plants after
acquisition they tested that using
purified virus as well and it still
happened which is very amazing to me um
so
seems like somehow in that case just the
virion is involved
and i don't entirely understand how that
could happen but you know
maybe the structural proteins are
somehow involved in that um
okay well i think we're a few minutes
over time anyway
um but thank you all for coming um
i see hand clapping um i guess i mean
are they allowed to unmute themselves to
applaud i feel like i'm talking to a
computer
congratulations thank you
all right well i have a defense to get
to
[Laughter]
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu